[Applause]
a year on and sultivica remains a broken
place
broken buildings broken infrastructure
and in the grip of this cruel winter
broken people
Anatoly limerenko has a face worn by War
he is 61 years old and he is the only
person still living in his badly damaged
nine-story block of flats
thank you
it is a hard climb to the seventh floor
place he still calls home
it is scarcely that so
it's cold it's really cold
we
used to cook and soup to keep him going
but there is no heating no hot water and
the toilet doesn't work because the
system water froze and it cracked
but despite it all he stays I have
nowhere else to go he says
it's scary to be on your own but when
there is no shelling it's bearable
and the bump here
during the days during the night
just after War Began we met Rahman in
soltifka ferrying supplies to the
desperate here between bombardments he
is still doing it
these women show us the flats destroyed
by Russian fire
where missiles went through the floor
and where the lives of neighbors came to
an end
and living next door to the burnt out
shell of an apartment we found 71 year
old nelia tuba who is often thought
about leaving
but instead stays with her bedridden
husband Petra
they do at least have Heating in this
block
but her fear is that the Russians will
try again to take the city
this place represents Putin's War not
against the Ukrainian military but
against the Ukrainian people 40
000 people lived here now it is barely a
handful and for them the conditions are
desperate
[Music]
Anatoly sitting watching jazz on a
television with barely a signal
this is what war has done to soltifka to
its few remaining people to the spirit
of what they say used to be a happy
place
[Music]